okay so let's start with the next talk
of the session it's given by Aditya
mascara from you talk about all
algorithms for matrix low-rank
approximation okay yeah thanks and
thanks for inviting me here so so I'm
going to talk about online algorithms
for low rank matrix approximation
problems so so we all know what low-rank
approximation is so it's these are some
very basic problems in analyzing large
data sets so we have in the stock will
consider two problems so one is PCA or
SVD for the purposes of this talk and
treat them both as the same
and usually it is used in applications
where you want to do a dimension
reduction while preserving the signal
so that's PC and column selection is a
problem where you want to find a small
subset of the columns of a matrix that
approximate the full matrix I'm going to
define these in a little bit and so
these are not just useful in practice
they're also very nice natural problems
in numerical linear algebra all right so
let me define start by defining low-rank
approximation or which I'll call loss of
PCA and the problem is basically you are
given a matrix U that you want to
approximate and you're given a small
number K which is much less than the
size of the than the dimension of the
columns and your goal is to find the K
dimensional subspace of Rd such that if
you project all the columns of U onto
that K dimensional subspace the error is
minimized this is I'm just setting up
notation here so you will be our matrix
and D will be the number of will be the
damage of the class and there'll be n
and we can also phrase this as the
following so you can say that for every
column of you you want to produce an
embedding which is a vector in a much
smaller dimensional space which is RK
and I'll call this embedding of UI as X
I and so what you want is that after the
embedding there should exist a recovery
matrix which I will call M such that u
minus M X is minimized so a recovery
matrix will basically be the will be a
basis for the s that we found in the
first in the first definition okay so
these two are the same just that this
definition turns out to be more useful
when I am defining the online version so
that's so that's this definition alright
so for both and yeah so there's an
extensive literature on this and I'm not
going to go too much into this but I
just want to mention that there this
problem has been studied in lots of
settings there are nearly linear time
algorithms in the input sparsity that
are known there are also streaming
algorithms for this problem and so on
there's a lot of literature and
apologies for just mentioning a couple
of them so the next problem that I'll
consider is column subset selection so
here we have we are given a matrix U and
now you want to find the space s that is
a span of only a small number of the
columns of U ok so we want to find K
columns of U such that projecting the
projecting the columns of U onto the
span of the chosen columns results in a
smaller
so that's the goal of column subset
selection instead of an arbitrary
subspace s we just want a span of K
columns so that's the
selection problem and this has been used
a lot for for feature selection that's
one of the applications and there are
also many efficient methods for
computations so it started with early
works of free scanner Impala and there
are lots of other works here as well but
I mentioned the first work that gave a
multiplicative approximation and some
works that followed that also very very
interesting and interestingly this
objective turns out to be closely
related to PCA as well so yeah so we
won't need that connection so I'm not
mentioning all right so that's the
column subset selection problem so for
both of these problems we'll be
interested in online algorithms for
these problems and what do we mean by
this so it just means that the point of
these columns show up one by one and we
need to make decisions as soon as these
points arrive and I will see what
decision means in a little bit and of
course as is the case in online
algorithms you always want to compute
compete with the optimum in hindsight
and the quality the ratio of the two
measures is called the comparative ratio
so so this is the setup so let's see
what we mean by online column selection
it's a column selection turns out to be
much easier to define in this notion
okay so you have a bunch of columns that
show up one after the other and whenever
a column arrives you must either choose
to pick it or ignore it okay so that's
what you want you want to do okay so
maybe you'll pick the first to ignore
this and the next two and so on so we we
either added to the set that we are
building or we just ignore it and your
goal is to compete with the best s in
hindsight of size K yeah
there's no assumption on call morning
yeah so this is all completely worst
case yeah and your goal is to compete
with the best s in hindsight and you
want drew you're allowed to use a little
bit more than as then k columns but not
much more than K so we would ideally
like s to be roughly key to some log
factors so that's so that's this problem
and this is in some sense some linear
algebra analog of hiring K secretaries
yeah actually it is log in n so yeah so
I will come to the exact guarantee that
you can show but log in K or constant
would be great yeah we're trying to get
1 plus epsilon multiplicative yes there
will also be some one batch no factors
yes complete what is your objective
you're projecting all the columns or to
this wanted the chosen you want you in
the future
yes that's technically the definitional
problem but in what we will show will
will actually show that even the
projection onto the stuff we've chosen
so far is small yeah but the objective
allows you to use stuff you'll choose in
the future yeah but so suppose we just
want the best single column I'm not
projecting all the directions on till
one even if it's even if the points are
Gaussian the columns are Gaussian the
approximation is going to be really
really bad not the approximation of how
I understand the but you mean
approximation in terms of the best haul
but approximation compared to say top
principal component would really yeah so
we will see that you need certain
assumptions and we will show what does
some sense you need in some sense yeah
so what exactly the same reason that it
could be very bad yeah so do you know it
we assume I will come to the assumptions
we need in a little bit yeah yeah so we
assume we know N and we assume a little
bit more than that also and for the case
kind of reasons he mentioned there are
lower bonds that show that you can't do
much if you don't assume this kind of
all right so let's so this is a setting
for online column selection okay so so
the online PC a problem the definite
in itself is somewhat non-trivial right
and here's where this embedding view of
PCA comes in okay so you get these
columns u 1 u 2 u 3 so on ok and what
you want to do is as soon as a column
arrives you want to commit to an
embedding X I of the column you want so
and this X I should be an embedding onto
a low dimensional space so as soon as
the column arise you want to commit to
an embedding and in the end you must
have this guarantee that you must
produce you must be able to produce some
subspace such that these X's can be
interpreted as projections onto that
subspace so in particular in the end you
want to show there exists some
orthogonal matrix M such that u minus M
X is has is small compared to the best
approximation error
so this is kind of a slightly tricky
definition but but yeah this is the one
that makes sense for online PC yeah all
right basically you're just I mean in
the world in suppose the dimension was
one yeah then you're basically trying to
produce the particular vector right sort
of coordinate by coordinate and the row
similar like yeah yeah but but yeah I
mean you can't quite do that so you need
something anytime the dimension of the
span of the XS at most k so the XS
should actually be short vectors so they
should be so your columns are d
dimensional vectors the X's are required
to be short window yeah yeah
they only have K or a little bit more
than K coordinates so all the results we
will show and actually most of the
results that are known for this they are
all by criteria so yeah so you will have
some terms that have epsilon factors one
by epsilon factors and also some login
factors actually that we don't know yeah
so yeah then that would be an
interesting question
yeah so that's the problem here yeah
you're the best right approximation or
is the best subset okay now this is the
best ranked approximation yeah so for
PCA we compare with PCA and yeah and
even for column selection since we are
doing by criterion we always compare
with alright so this is the setup for
online BCA okay so so what is known
about this problem so it turns out this
problem was defined by boots a DS
garbled Carlin and needle Liberty and
what they showed is that you can produce
an embedding into K times polyline
dimensional space which means that each
of these X vectors has dimension that is
roughly K poly log n it will be always
bound by that and you will obtain an
additive error of epsilon times the
Frobenius norm of the original matrix so
this is the best known approximation for
this and note that this is actually a
much harder model than streaming
algorithms for PC because you have to
commit to an embedding before you
actually see the rest of the matrix and
nothing essentially is known for online
CSS and we will actually see some lower
bounds showing that if you don't assume
anything this is very difficult
all right so the motivating question is
are there efficient multiplicative
approximations to both these problems
both are pretty natural questions and so
can you get multiplicative
approximations to online versions of
this and what we show is that there's
actually a simple variant of what is
known as adaptive sampling in this
literature and it it gives a 1 plus
epsilon comparative ratio and it uses
something like K times poly in this
actually log n divided by epsilon
columns as if assuming some two
conditions okay so the two conditions
are following so firstly you must have a
rough estimate
of what the optimum error is in the
sense that you want
so by opt I just mean the actual error
like you - UK the Frobenius norm okay
and we need we need a fairly rough
estimate but we need some kind of an
estimate of this quantity so like a poly
n factor and the second condition you
need is that the largest singular value
the I mean so the ratio of the largest
singular value to this rank K error is
at most polynomial so there's nothing
very important about the polynomial
otherwise logs of those terms will show
up in these bounds provide the list
where like you know one of them is gonna
be good yeah so that's also fine as long
as the number of things that you have is
small that will show up in this in this
bar as a matter of fact okay yeah so so
these are two assumptions and yeah so we
can actually so we can't quite show that
these things are necessary for online
PCA and that's due to a non trivial
reason so but for online column
selection you can show that assumptions
of this kind are necessary okay so we
can show that the number of columns you
choose must necessarily depend on these
factors so that is something so the
other thing about a result if the die
algorithm itself is very is fairly
simple
and it's a variant of adaptive sampling
and it's inspired by this really nice
algorithm for online clustering okay due
to Myers so we'll start by looking at
that algorithm okay so so this is so
let's for now consider this online
k-means clustering problem okay so you
are this is the usual k-means that we've
seen times right so you and this is
online version of the problem right so
points arrive
and each time you either add you to s or
you ignore you okay so the points you
show up one by one you either add it to
your set that you're building or you
ignore it and in the end you want two
things you want that the size of the set
you end up with a small it's roughly K
and also if you compute the k-means
objective using s as the Centers you get
a value that's almost the same as all T
so this is the natural online version of
k-means question and what Meyerson
showed is that there's this very simple
algorithm that works if if we know what
the value of the optimum is and so so
that wisdom is simply this so you you
see these points one by one see this
point you one by one and you add you to
s with probability that's effectively K
times the distance to this to the things
you've seen so far
divided by the estimate for the object
you have okay so so in this sense this
is very much like adaptive sampling so
but it's a one-shot adaptive sampling
it's like an online version of adaptive
sample like you just see one thing at a
time
so that's so this is meyerson's
algorithm and there are many questions
here right like firstly why is the cost
small and secondly why is the number of
columns you choose small and so both of
these need to be bonded and so let me
just talk about the cost first so for
the cost so the idea to analyze this
algorithm is suppose you look at one of
the optimal clusters okay so you look at
one of the optimal clusters this is one
of the optimal clusters that we started
with and we see what is and these points
showed up at some point of time in in
the algorithm and we see what is the
values what are the values that of these
dus squared that that we saw in this
process okay and if the sum was more
than this C over K then you can see that
these probabilities add up to something
more than log N
and so this means that one of the points
from this C has to be chosen this is
slightly hand wavy proof but but yeah so
this can be made formal so one of these
points can be chosen needs to be chosen
and from that point on you can argue
that the error will be small that's the
idea behind this analysis and if there's
some for the whole cluster was smaller
than C okay then you're in good shape
already because this means that this
then this cluster doesn't contribute
more than C over K to the objective so
there were only K clusters so it's still
good so this is a very simple strategy
that so this gives a bound and the
objective and you can use this very
similar analysis to also show that you
won't pick too many centers so that's
yeah so that's my sense analysis and so
the cool thing which is why this whole
analysis works is that the sampling
probability is cleanly tied to the to
the objective function right to the
contribution that a point is making to
the object that's the reason you're able
to do this nice analysis
all right so right so motivation was to
ask are there similar clean sampling
based algorithms for problems like PC
and TSS so that's one of our questions
that you want to play so let me describe
the setting at least that I'll restrict
to during the talk
okay so we'll only consider PC a version
if you won't consider contradiction and
you'll always call the input matrix is U
and I'm going to assume for the sake of
the talk that we know the following
quantities and almost exactly okay so we
know the optimum which is the rank K
error for you okay so this I will call
it C so this plays a very similar role
as the exceeded here okay so you assume
that we know this exactly you also know
a bound on the largest singular value
it's a Sigma maximum so these are two
assumptions that I will make for the
sake of the top
all right so so now let's try to proceed
how this tight explain how this
algorithm will work okay so the
framework is as I described before you
get these columns and you want whenever
a column comes you want to output its
embedding so what we will do is we'll
always maintain a subspace s ok so in
clustering they were always a set of
points as we were maintained now we
maintain subspace ok so I want to define
an analogous algorithm here so now we
will maintain a subspace s and every
time a point comes you will pick a basis
or rather you will always have one fixed
basis for this earth and you will embed
this point UI into that subspace so this
will give an embedding of dimension
which is equal to the dimension of s but
will have some kind of an upper bound
which we call our ok so this is the
maximum number that we will output and
you will pad zeroes so that you always
output an R dimensional vector so this
is the framework that we are considering
that each time you get a vector you
embed onto the s that you have so far
you add some 0 so as to make sure you
always output the same dimension so this
yeah all right so the whole point is how
do you pick this s and so an ideal
algorithm if you want to be inspired by
myosin completely would be to say would
be to do something like this right so
you know opt exactly so you can say that
every time a column shows up you add it
to this subspace and you take the span
of the original space Plus this column
and you do that with probability which
is proportional to K times the
projection that you I had orthogonal to
the subspace so far divided by this this
number X so this is a very natural
choice of to do this and you let's call
this number P I so this is for the
column UI this is the probability of
adding UPI depends on what s we had so
far
all right and note that this is very for
those of you who know of adaptive
sampling for PCM so for this is like a
one pass adapt to something it's just
picks one out
and so what
so one thing with this too is that if
this algorithm always I mean if this if
you are able to prove good guarantees
for this very simple algorithm you
actually get online algorithms for both
pca and column selection because you are
actually choosing some columns and
adding them to s each time all right but
it turns out this simple algorithm we
actually don't know how to analyze okay
so we believe that this also gives a
good approximation which we don't know
how to analyze but it turns out that
there are still things from this
algorithm that I mean there's still
parts of it that we can analyze ok so so
one simple claim which turns out to be
useful later on is if you do this
process the number of large pis is small
okay so what do I mean by large so
specifically you want to claim that the
number of indices I for which P I equals
1 remember P I was defined as this
quantity for which P I will be equal to
1 is small I will say what small means
little so and the reason for this is
that if you have such a thing then every
such UI firstly it will always be chosen
because P I will be 1 right and every
such UI has a large component orthogonal
to the previous ones ya know so the
number of I for which P is equals 1 is
small it's okay so the number of such
indices is small yeah the size of the
sector
all right and yes and the way we tried
show this is by saying that if you have
a bunch of pies that are all one then it
means that each corresponding UI has a
large component orthogonal to all the
previous vectors chosen one so various
maybes chosen ones yeah yeah so previous
ones that also had this property is for
devil use okay so so this is so this is
a guarantee that we have and and we want
to show that this kind of a thing is
impossible and for this there's a very
simple geometric lemma that you can
write okay so if you have a bunch of
vectors u1 through you are okay so it's
a sequence of vectors such that for
every I the projection of U I orthogonal
to all the vectors that preceded it yeah
I'm just introducing some notation here
it's got PI sub I minus 1 so if assume
that that number is at least gamma so if
you have this kind of a guarantee then
you have many singular values in
particular you have something like R
divided by roughly log in singular
values of of this matrix of you that are
at least gamma bite okay so you have
matrix with a bunch of columns every
column has at least a gamma component
orthogonal to the span of the previous
guys we are saying that this matrix has
at least R by log and columns the
directly sorry are my log and singular
values that are at least gamma by 2 so
this is this is an ordered versioning
version of what is called this leave one
out distance okay so those of you know
and there you don't actually look at the
component or song it's the previous one
you look at the component orthogonal to
everybody else and there you can
actually get that R by two singular
values are large okay and you don't lose
this Login but here it turns out you
have to lose this law
all right so but this is the lemma
all right and for now let's pretend that
this number is a slogan so why is so why
is this relevant to us right so we
wanted to show that having many large
pis is impossible like many pies that r1
is impossible and now let's suppose that
you had R of these P is a tall one then
what this lemma tells us is that if you
just restrict the matrix to these
columns to the concert if chosen then
you have 10k log in are being at least
10k log n so if you divide by log n so
the so if you use this lemma it tells
you that our by log and singular values
are all large and so you get that u has
at least 10k singular values that are at
least this C divided by 4 and this is a
contradiction because the rank K error
is only is only exceeded right because
so you can't have too many large
singular values you can't have something
like 10k singular values that are more
than c1 so this is a way to bound to
bound this I so what you've shown is
that having a large number of pis is
impossible so not so the lemma is
actually pretty easy to show okay so
it's it basically follows from just two
views of the volume of the simplex
divide defined by this defined by these
uisce we know that every UI has a good
component orthogonal to the previous
ones so if you just use the base times
height formula for the volume and you
use it inductively you get that the
volume is at least gamma to the R and
then you use the fact that the volume is
also the product of singular values and
this is why the Sigma max comes into the
picture so you kind of one big singular
value it's contributing all the one so
ok so so this is roughly the proof of
this length
all right so so that's what we can show
like having many large P ice is not
possible so before we move on I want to
mention one brief issue with the case of
small p ice right
so we said large p ice is okay right and
P is defined like this and the problem
which is the reason we can't analyze
this algorithm fully is that in some
sense if you if you have a bunch of
columns that have small P is right we
don't sample them but we don't have any
memory of what those columns were right
because if you don't sample them you
can't lose track of all information
about these columns okay so in some
sense we don't see anything of them and
you can think of some potential based
analogues of what we saw before but
turns out that they don't work either
the only fix we know is using a slight
variant of the cell values right so I
don't think the values themselves help
yeah I think the vectors are also
important it's like you could have I
guess the two examples is you had many
vectors it would all align the same way
all having small P I versus many vectors
that are all very different and all had
same VI you need some way of
differentiating between them so the so
that wouldn't be proposing is in some
sense so it's a it's an algorithm that
proceeds in phases okay and the way it
does it is you have for now assume that
all the PI's are less than one just for
simplicity so what you do is you divide
these vectors in two phases so that
every face in every face the peas add up
to one okay so and and after every phase
we add one direction to this space s
that we maintain
so this is how the algorithm proceeds
and this vector W that's added is in
sometimes a summary of all the vectors
in that face so this is the idea of
hints algorithm and all right so and so
initially you start with s equals fie
and after and these are a bunch of
columns whose peas add up to 1 and at
this point you add one vector and you
keep going so so this is the algorithm
so what is and and the intuition is that
in some sense you are adding roughly 1
vector when even the previous algorithm
were added 1 vector but you are adding a
much better vector in some sense ok so
you have a summary of everything that
happened in that phase so yeah so so
quickly let's see what the summary of a
vector is all right so so summary of a
phase is right so if you have a phase
that consists of U Wii U 1 u 2 a B of T
we do a very simple summary which is
basically the random linear combination
of the UI's so this is the vector that
we will add at the end of each phase and
what is the and these signs are chosen
uniformly at random so if a ship's a
memory them you just have a memory of
this one vector so yeah so you keep
track of one vector that you will keep
adding in this yeah so that's the reason
it's not much memory
so right so and the reason we do this is
because firstly I mean you can see that
the expected length of this vector is
the sum of squares of these lengths but
more importantly for any projection pie
because predictions are linear you have
that the expected length of the
projection of W is the sum of these
square length of the projections and
this is nice because it gives us two
things okay so the first thing is if you
look at the projection orthogonal to s
where s was the S at the beginning of
the face then with a good probability
you have that the projection of this W
orthogonal to this s is roughly the
projection some of the projection
squares of all these individual vectors
in that face
so this just is because of this fact
that I said before right so the
expectation is the same use some basic
concentration bound gives something like
this another thing which is actually a
slightly tricky thing is that if you
consider the projection orthogonal to
that to the optimal PCA space for the
entire matrix note that we have no idea
what the space is but just for the sake
of analysis let's consider PI K to be
the optimal KPC a subspace for the
entire minute okay then you have that
even this kind of a bound holds right so
the projection of W is not much more
than the sum of projections of all these
other vectors so let's see how these two
bonds are useful so I want to say that
these two bounds immediately imply that
the number of phases are small okay so
one thing to note is that these bonds
don't always hold they hold with
reasonable probability but the
probability is more than some constant
because this one or two 3/4 this one
also holds it some 3/4 so so let's
assume all phases are successful I want
to show that the number of such phases
is small
and so the reason is the following so by
the first part of the bond we can show
that every phase has a large projection
or the W at the end of each phase has a
large projection orthogonal to all the
to the s so far it's just two orthogonal
to all the WS added so far this is nice
because this allows us to use this
geometric lemma that we define so it
says that if your number of hours is is
more than K log n then what it shows is
that the matrix W has a rank K error of
at least this C so we're not done yet
right because this is some new matrix W
all we showed is that it has a large
rank here and now this where the second
part comes in right so the second part
shows that if you take took the optimal
kpc a subspace the entire matrix the
rank K error of the W's you're adding
was only smaller than this and these we
know add up to exactly exceed because
that was the definition of the rank
error for the whole matrix so so that's
the reason so that so that contradicts
this too so this is why you can't have
more than something like K log n columns
K log n phases alright so this is the
this is basically in the proof and so
this is the proof that you want add too
many that the space won't get too large
so now why is the error small this is
also very simple
note how the pis are defined right so
they were basically this min of one and
this okay and so and these P I is in a
phase we're always adding up to one
which meant that these numbers were
adding up to one so which means that the
error which is this term in every phase
is at most something like four K by four
time Cy key
and this is again not the similarity
with the smile since an abscess right so
it's basically it's like one cluster and
yeah so so over all the phases we have
that the some of these projection errors
is there for at most something like log
n times this times this C because the
number of phases was 100 K log n so
that's so that's the bond we have and so
the S you have in the end has a log in
compared to ratio so that's the argument
so far okay so this is good but we have
a log n factor here but it's a
multiplicative factor all right so how
do we now get to 1 plus epsilon factor
okay so so first thing to ask is what if
you're allowed two passes over the data
so the same data same order you get two
passes so now it's somewhat easy to see
right so you can use our algorithm to
obtain the space s and now you can use
one of these additive approximations
that were known before and you can feed
the leftover vectors to this additive
approximation if I left over I just mean
the parts that were not covered by the
span of s and you can feed those vectors
to the additive approximation and then
overall you get a multiplicative factor
so this gives a 1 plus epsilon compared
to ratio and just just be sure the
embedding will be the concatenation of
the two an inner product of these
factors with random signs right is it so
this is the span of such vectors so most
of these networks will be left over
right like
Oh nonono so sorry what I mean by left
over here is is the part of is the
component of these UIs that are
orthogonal to the s so far okay then
there are some yeah they just feed yeah
so we are getting two passes right so in
the second pass whenever you see a
vector you projected to the you take the
component orthogonal to the s you
obtained in the first part and you use
feed that in to this additive
approximation algorithm we use this as a
black box
all right and this gives 1 plus epsilon
comparative ratio and so it turns out if
you think about it for a second you can
actually do these two passes in just one
pass and the reason is you can imagine
doing the the algorithm that we've been
doing okay so you get these columns and
you you come up with these different SS
but in parallel suppose you send the
projection orthogonal to the S so far to
a copy of this this additive
approximation algorithm that we are
saying and that it was there in this
work right so so you just send the
orthogonal component to the as a
blackboard to it to this black box off
the yeses of the projection so far and
you just and you need to now output an
embedding and you output the
concatenation of the two embeddings okay
so the whatever the embedding we got
plus whatever embedding these guys it
turns out that because we have a bound
not just on the projection in the end
but on a projection some of the of these
kind of terms at every step this is
roughly what Robbie was asking earlier
if you don't wear that our guarantee
actually gives a bound over the running
sum is that that is at most k long at
most some log n factor of the oft so
this is the reason we you can do this
two passes in just a single pass and
turns out that this gives a 1 plus
epsilon compared to ratio for online PC
okay okay okay so I will be done I'm
almost done
okay so all right so yeah so one thing
you ask is is is this yeah one thing we
can show is that the same kind of result
is also possible for column selection
the only trick there is how do you avoid
keeping drag of the sketch of a phase
right here it was important that we had
this vector W it was a sketch of a phase
well it turns out if you sample only
like login things in every phase then
this actually still works out so another
thing I wanted to talk about is the
importance of knowing or guessing the
optimum yeah oh yeah so I actually so it
so we don't think that this that that
kind of reasoning gives some bond on the
rank here so it gives the bound or if
you want to approximate the whole matrix
but we don't know if if it gives a bound
for the rank K yeah we can talk about we
don't know the PCA right so we don't how
do you but you don't know how to serve
the
you have we can talk about this offline
I guess yeah yeah so that's a good
question yeah we also or not yeah but to
the best of our knowledge we don't know
how to make that kind of machinery work
yeah okay so all right so so what is
yeah so one thing I want to comment
about is the importance of knowing or
guessing the optimum and I wanted to
yeah just say maybe this is a kind of
example to you anything but for problems
like column selection if you have a
basic some lower bound L and some upper
bound you if any constant competitive
algorithm must pick at least some log of
u by L columns okay and this is why we
have these assumptions that these ratios
are bounded by polynomial and the reason
is that you can just have completely
orthogonal vectors show up of like very
different lengths and and the online
algorithm doesn't know if these vectors
lengths keep growing or if they'll just
stay the same so in some sense we have
we don't have a way of getting around
this kind of a bomb this is for column
selection so PCA you can do something
interesting okay so in remember in PCA
your vectors keep growing a lot in
length then you can start reusing the
coordinates in the embedding so this is
I won't go into the details but this
turns out to be it's a weird thing that
is possible for PCA okay so it might be
that for PCA you can actually get an
algorithm without any such assumptions
all right so let me end that okay so
there are a bunch of questions that came
up during the talks the first thing is
that this this one path set up to
sampling the very basic algorithm
inspired by myosin does it itself work
so this we don't quite know and so the
other thing is other algorithms without
any dependence on these condition number
parameters right so at least for the
case of PCA
yeah and the other thing is avoiding the
knowledge of optics so all these are
natural open questions and of course
there are lots of open questions when we
go to this how about other norms in
terms of approximation right but for
spectral norm yeah I mean all bets are
off because even for column selection I
don't quite know how to do this all
right so yeah and you could ask various
other addresses any questions okay there
were many questions during class not
stirred your question was about depends
on the condition yeah so actually for
both of these things we also have a log
dependence on this not quite the
condition number but this ratio between
the Sigma max and the rank K error and
that we don't know if there are like
reasonable algorithms that can avoid
that
surely not yeah well if you're at least
not for PCA for column selection I think
this kind of low bonds can be shown what
about PCA is unclear if we can show such
because you essentially have the power
to reuse you can you can fix an
embedding and later claim that that was
not the projection I had in mind I had
it there's a different projection that
still works so you can play such things
any more questions okay no let's thank
the speaker again copy break country